There are several other properties in fault tolerance
in addition to dependability. One of them is
reliability, and unlike dependability, which is the property
of the system that we can trust it
to perform its function, reliability is actually something
we can measure. To measure reliability, we consider
the system to always be in one of
these two states. The normal state is the service
accomplishment state, so the system is providing
the service that we want it to provide.
The other state is service interruption. So
this is, at this time, the service is
not providing, it's not accomplishing the service that we expect from it. So
reliability can now be defined by measuring continuous service
accomplishment. A typical measure for reliability is mean
time to failure or MTTF. And that basically
is how long do we have service accomplishment before
we get into the next service interruption. So it's not enough, for example,
that over the past two years the
system has been in service accomplishing for one
year. If we have a system that
accomplishes service for a month, then is interrupted
for a month, then accomplishes service again
because it's been fixed, then it's again
interrupted for a month, in that case, the main time to failure will be one
month. That's how long you have of
continuous service accomplishment, on average, between periods of
service interruption. Another popular metric related to
this is the availability. Availability measures service accomplishment
as a fraction of overall time. So reliability measures how long do we get
service accomplishment until the next failure. Availability
measures what percentage of time were we in
the service accomplishment state. So if the system on average was half in this
state and half in this state, then availability will be 50%. 50% of the time,
the system was accomplishing service. But reliability
will be on average how long each of
these accomplishment states lasted until we saw the
interruption. So for example, if you have one
year of service followed by one year of service interruption you get 50% here,
you get one year here. If you get one month at a time for two years you get
50% here, but you get one month here
instead of one year. So for availability, in
addition to the mean time to failure, we
need to know the mean time to repair, or
MTTR, so this is once the system has
service interruption how long does it last until it
goes back to the service accomplishment state. And
then our availability is the mean time to failure.
How long did it function properly at the time, divided by the overall
time, which was the mean time to failure plus the mean time to repair.
After that, you're back in the accomplishment state. So this is how long we
had both service accomplishment and service interruption,
and this is just the service accomplishment.